The Joe Rogan experience,
those algorithms, they, they,
the real problem is people think that a
lot of those algorithms are essentially
designed to get you angry or pissed off.
So he wants the next thing take.
Yeah. [inaudible] our children,
what are they teaching our children next?
Yeah.
This is the problem with
illegal immigration. I knew
there's a fucking problem,
you know, and then next thing you know,
you just more and more angry. Yeah.
That's like, the argument with
Facebook too is that they're,
they're trying to figure out
what gets people to engage.
And so the algorithm realize what you
engage with and then that's what they show
you more of and what gets
people to engage. It's shit
that makes him mad. Yeah.
Yeah, totally. It keeps me wanting to,
I'll watch you fight videos on Facebook
all day. They really do well, just like,
you know, like brawls in the
schoolyard or like, you know, just,
it just keeps going. I'm like, Oh man,
what's going to happen here? Let's get,
do they? Yeah, little bit. Yeah.
Well, you know, I'm not, uh,
I don't do much of the fighting,
so when I see it it's like, oh,
this is interesting. Who's going
to win this one? And then the Ahca,
when the underdog wins. Yeah.
I enjoy watching it. Yeah.
I mean I will watch them.
I want you to do sockets. Obviously
someone's about to die. Right.
That seemed like a good,
like couple of punches to the face.
Well the best ones are when
someone deserves it. Yes.
So those are the ones you enjoy when
someone's being a real dick. Yeah.
Someone's like, listen man, you're
being a dick. Yeah. So I just saw one a,
there's a guy on there,
it was a,
I want to say like a old Middle Eastern
couple that are on a subway and this
dude's like smacking his
wife in the face like that.
And there's this other guys he's across
from him and he's recording it and he's
like, no, not, not in front of me.
And he walked over there and say,
he told him like eight times to stop
and then just a punching the shit out of
him. So it's nice to see it,
you know? Yeah. There's one, uh,
of a guy, a, oh,
it's like a bus and some guys running
his mouth to this old white guy who's
obviously a like an x Vietnam
vet. And he's telling him
like, just leave it alone,
man.
Leave it alone.
And he comes down there and then he walks
up to the front and they just beat the
shit out of him and you just see blood
coming out of his face and it's like,
you know, he started this,
he engaged that whole thing.
The guy was walking away and then
he goes, the backup ones. Yeah.
Those are the best ones. Yeah.
When someone deserves it. Yeah.
How many, like that's the thing about
like a guy smacking his wife and public.
Yeah.
Like how often does he smack her that
he's so confident that he'll just smack
her in front of everybody.
Right. That's be, um,
he must think it's acceptable and
everyone else was cool with it.
I must think that he could just
get away with things. Yeah.
Sometimes people just think they can
get away with things. Yeah. It was a,
there was not many people on
that bus, uh, in this video.
Mostly that guy wasn't even paying
attention to them or that most people just
going to be too scared to say anything.
[inaudible] yeah,
that's what I mean,
that this is where it gets real scary
because that is the best argument for the
end of all privacy is that no one would
ever be able to do anything like that
because the whole world will be
watching. Yeah, exactly. Honest like you,
you might, it depends on what kind
of action you could take. Yeah.
If you could literally see everything
that's happening at any time everywhere in
the world.
Yeah.
Well now that everyone's got cam, so it's
like it's close. It's close. Yeah. Right.
Then they're going to have those
fucking foldable things. Cops on us.
You're keeping a, yeah, the people on
us now it a little bit until too much.
Alcohol's involved something to it
because if you think about like,
like Dan Kennedy did a speech on secrecy,
it was like in 1961 or 62,
but how a boring secrecy is how
dangerous it is for a free society.
And uh, they're basically talking about
secret societies and secret, you know,
packs in the government.
And he was basically,
I think a lot of it was him talking
about some of the shady shit that you
experienced and intelligence
agencies and all,
but when you have like kings or when
you have people that are in power,
like how do they wield that power?
One of the ways they will, their PR,
it's all secrecy.
If they want to execute people,
they're going to kill people
towards, it's all secret, right?
No one's the world is not privy to
it. Like what happened to them? They,
they took them to a bunker, so I'm, yeah,
and they're beating the shit out of him.
Torturing them. Secret like North
Korea. Yeah, exactly. They are,
they're just isolated from
the rest of the world.
And who knows what the
hell he's doing over there.
So if we just know the stuff that
he allows us to know. Yeah. No,
that's the perfect example. Yeah.
Of Power and secrecy, right? Yeah.
They just take you in, make you disappear.
He's executed a bunch of people.
Oh yeah. The, we don't even know.
I'm sure that over close to
the tip of the iceberg on that.
I'm sure that still goes on
here too. Well, yeah. I'm sure.
I'm sure people are killing people
for someone right now, you know?
And some of them deserve it. Yeah.
Give him an extra one for me right now.
Stop being a traveler.